hey everybody it's Mike from
immortalflows and welcome to today's
video today is a Friday January 6 2023
it was the non-farm payrolls and uh once
that number came out you know the market
uh went berserko and it'll be
interesting we'll see you know the
market is up about two percent today uh
next week we got CPI and we'll see if
CPI can give it a further boost up now
again you know I'm not an economist I
don't try to be an economist I don't try
to dissect what the numbers mean
um personally I think there's
the economy is not as good as the
numbers are saying so you know that
being said let's take a look at today's
uh market now before we begin you know
be sure to subscribe to the channel if
you haven't you know we're trying to get
a video out every single day and you
know keep those comments coming if
there's something you want to see a
video on so coming into the morning
session today
um you know we had again a very tight
range as to be expected it's the
non-farm payrolls uh release coming out
this that came out this morning and you
know we had a 49 high and during the
London session uh we kept making these
new lows you know initially our low is
31 and a half uh we got down to 29 and a
half down to 24. uh was that 24 even and
then just before the number came out we
got as low as
um 18 and three quarters or was it 19 uh
right there 19. so you know basically 49
down to 19
um a 30 point range very quiet but you
expect that coming into today's uh
economic release now it was interesting
to note that the market was selling off
pretty steadily coming into the number
now you know there are studies that have
been done I remember this from you know
back in the 90s when I was you know
first getting started in in trading
um the historical
back test had shown that I think it was
like close to 70 percent and it's like
around 65 68 percent of non-farm payroll
days
close up now today was you know
obviously a big up day you know this is
what the market did
um you know it closed you know it was
almost a two percent higher a lot of
times it will sort of close you know
maybe a third of a percent higher or
something like that but today was a nice
big strong uh trending day
once we sort of once the cash opened we
came back and sort of kissed the opening
price and then we took off but I'm going
to take a look at some of this
interesting order flow
um and sort of just go through it and
you know maybe you could get some little
bits of information that you could use
in your own trading so let's take a look
at the normal footprint chart so this is
your footprint chart now you know any
realistic day trader is not going to be
trading
um coming into the number or immediately
afterwards at least 5 10 15 minutes now
non-farm payrolls is a day
I actually don't get involved in the
market you know I've
traded through enough non-front payroll
days to know that I I don't have good
results on these days there's a day I
just like to sit back and watch and sort
of take a look at the order flow see
interesting things you know it's a day
where there's a lot of excitement and
the Market's moving quickly and it's
moving fast and you know sometimes I get
over my skis out
and you know just end up doing stupid
things you know
don't do stupid things when you're
trading I guess is a
the topic for today but when the number
came out right you see it just shot
right up now I believe uh was it last
month's non-farm payroll or or last
month's CPI when it came out you just
saw a void in liquidity there was
nothing on the bid or the offer here at
least you know the market the number
came out everyone just lifted the offer
someone just came immediately lifted
everything up we had basically a 50
point bar
um this is a one minute chart you know
when the numbers came out now once the
number came out obviously we spiked up
again we were trading real right near
the low we had just made the low of the
day about uh seven minutes earlier
and again you know if this number came
out the other way who knows we would
probably be trading 30 in the 3600s
right now or or maybe even lower
but the market uh was encouraged by it
Market uh spiked up here let's take a
look how up here at our high again
decent volume 16 000 contracts and then
we sort of closed inside and then went
inside okay fine you know this is why I
tend to stay away from non-farm payroll
days because you what you have is
exactly this you get the big bar up and
then you just go inside for the next 20
30 minutes until the cash opens right
then the market is now starting to find
which way it really wants to move
because that's where the volume is
coming and now it's not to say you can't
trade this junk here you can volumes are
decent but it's moving pretty quick and
you know you can get yourself chopped up
and stopped out uh pretty easily so
let's take a look at how the market was
once the cash session opened okay so
cash opened what happens you get this
little move back up towards the high at
this point you know cash opens we're
trading around you know 38 60 62 roughly
pulls back a little bit before it shoots
up now what was interesting on this
move up is it's going up okay Point
control is going higher you've seen some
binding balances in this bar this bar
um but look at the Delta 900 850 500 500
and then it turns negative here turns to
minus 700 minus 1400
it's just yeah think about it right you
got to put it in context it's not just
about reading what's the Delta doing
okay well see the Delta is 979 850 593
527. you got to be saying okay what's
Delta doing as we're trading back up
towards the high if we're going to look
to possibly take off this high is Delta
getting stronger or is it average I mean
it doesn't have to necessarily get
stronger to take out the high but is
indecent or not and you know honestly
even though it's decreasing 979 850 500
500 it's not like 979
you know 850 and then
120 593 is still decent you know 527 is
still decent okay maybe it can possibly
make a run at the high that doesn't mean
oh I got to get long no okay you just
sit back and watch what the market is
doing but then the selling comes in
right you see one two three four five
six seven eight seven or eight selling
imbalances in this bar here
I see a strong negative Delta minus 700
okay well maybe we're not going to take
off that high but who knows it could
reverse and come back up but then you
see another bar it's got twice as much
negative Delta and again one two three
you know maybe about eight selling
imbalances so okay I sort of kiss that
idea goodbye for now that we're gonna
take out this high
but more importantly okay if we're not
going to take out that high what are we
going to do are we going to go sideways
or we're going to sell off
so it's kind of weak you know I say week
but you know it's not as strong going up
into the high but the selling off is
obviously quite strong right this is
your biggest Delta one way or the other
positive or negative since the cash
opened here
um this was minus 900 this is minus 1400
we did have a plus 900 here but it's
your strongest one
so right at this point you got all these
selling imbalances all these selling
imbalances
you didn't make that run
and take out the high you got within
about a point and a half of that height
and you're starting to sell off you know
the the way you should be looking at
this is you know this Market should go
lower and it does right it goes
basically from you know the 57 area down
to the 47 area in a just over a minute
right that that's that's a 10 point move
in a minute
um you know maybe I'm old and I remember
when s PS were trading below a thousand
and you know
a 10 point move now that was like your
whole day's range but um you know so
that's why nowadays it's it's much more
interesting uh Market to trade
and boom click 10 point drop right and
again big strong negative Delta here
right minus 700 minus 1400 minus 1469
but the trade to take immediately the
quick trade
right here quick 10 points okay and then
drop further actually I mean it did go
sideways and then it pulls back towards
that opening price 38.33 now
um
me personally I like to use the opening
price as essentially the closing price
of the previous day there's usually it's
right around the same price you know but
it's not the the official closing price
because obviously it's the reopen
generally there's not a lot that happens
sometimes there is something but I treat
the opening prices essentially the same
as closing price and when I see the
market sort of rotate around there you
sort of come back and stop
it's telling me once I see it sort of
stop you know and trade back and forth
It's Going one bar two bars then okay
maybe we're just gonna hang around here
for a while again it's a non-farm
payroll day I don't expect the market to
be unchanged for very long right I
either expect it to be a nice update or
a nice down day I don't expect it to be
basically hanging around unchanged
there's just too much volatility in the
market and it does it just sort of hangs
around for one bar two bars three bars
four
five six now it starts to move away okay
as it starts moving away you've seen
this bar with a bunch of imbalances and
it's sort of working its way up
pulls back a little bit but this has
worked out really interesting in my
opinion here this bar right here this
big green let's say big green candle the
big one was here but this nice green
candle with the big negative Delta minus
693 and why is it
such a big negative Delta excuse me
because at 53 and a half actually 43 and
a half
there was a big bid that came in there
at 43 and a half you know for
um you know you see what was left what
traded there 748 748 contracts so what
had happened is the market had rallied
up from 33 all the way up to about you
know almost 50. oh it did hit 50. um
then it pulls back and it's going
sideways
and then now the big buyer stepped in
okay two One support the market
and two sort of trigger off this buying
that took place so what happened right
we dropped from 50 down to 40.
sort of working our way back up someone
comes in
what are they three and a half bid on
700 boom right here then I don't say
that spooked the market but you know all
those guys that look at the order book
at a depth map a heat map
all of a sudden they see that and
they're thinking they start buying
it right that's why you see look at this
big aggressive buying here basically all
the way up to 47 and a half so from
three and a quarter up to seven and a
half
just someone just lifting the offers
whatever's there they're just buying
everything so basically
I don't know if this uh you know what
was here
kind of spilled over in here because
remember it traded at three and a half
and then the bar traded a little bit
down because it closed below this level
but this was your first sign that
there's some supportive buying coming
into the market now you know what what's
interesting is
you know you hear people talk about uh
you know Market moving on supply and
demand and you know when there's more
buying than selling the market will move
up it's actually when there's more
demand you know in the market in in the
sense of Supply coming in and being sold
right when people are coming in and
demanding you know I want to buy more I
want to buy more and you're seeing this
big volume come in 750 you know that
basically you're that's your sign right
I talked about looking at a Delta
footprint yesterday if you're looking at
a Delta footprint this Delta here is
like 700 and
nine contracts right which is huge
at a price level
on a minute chart in the minis okay
actually be huge in in most markets
other than the interest rates but
that's a big volume there okay then the
market boom some another buyer just came
in and just started lifting every single
offer sweeping through the order book
there is some counter trades in here but
I could tell by the the zeros in here
there wasn't much counter trade and next
thing you know we're trading 47 and a
half 48s and 49s and this bar trades all
the way up it does go all the way up to
seven and a three quarters
before you know closing down in here
this this bar was a big bar as well
seven and three quarters down to
um what was that two two and a half
42 and a half up to 57 and three
quarters so again nice bind but the sign
was in this volume right here this 748
this big imbalance this big negative
Delta right what you have is look at the
the negative Delta 693 it's closing
Within
95 percentile of its Min Delta and it's
a green candle so I know that there was
some supportive buying coming in there
really all you're looking for is you
know the follow through and you get it
right in this bar and then the market
went up and uh
then it was pretty much Off to the Races
pretty much the rest of the day when we
did get some pullbacks you know there
did look like some potential
um short opportunities right we did pull
back here but when we were making these
highs up in here
this is this is how you could tell when
a market is flow driven
as opposed to any other Market condition
and I liked it you know the way that
what I describe a flow driven Market as
is a market that
basically disregard whatever technical
indicators you're using because it's
just driven by the flow now I know I
know there was I saw some people saying
well you know this buying is you know
people covering their shorts from before
yeah there's probably some some of that
taking place I mean obviously yesterday
you know where we were trading you know
we spent most of you know after the cash
that's today's Cash yesterday right it
was right around here you know we're
trading basically between 50 and you
know 25
most of yesterday
right and we sort of failed to come back
down towards that yesterday's you know
the 25-ish area
um you know I don't know people say yeah
there's people covering their shorts
from yesterday yeah probably
um
you know but really what you're looking
for really what you like to see is you
know is it potentially new Longs coming
into the market
it's one thing to be covering your
shorts but if you're starting to see
potentially new Longs then that's going
to give you a good idea of
what type of Market you're in and if
it's new Longs then that's going to be a
flow driven Market if it's a flow driven
Market take your technical indicators
throw them in the garbage
all right because how can I tell is when
I start seeing strong sell-offs like
this which should be a strong sell-offs
but when I'm looking at you know the
Deltas up here near the high quite
strong negative and it just reverses
right back on you pretty quick you know
these what the selling is taking place
in here is probably people covering
their lungs that got you know the day
traders that got long earlier they're
selling out
then the buying comes back in strong and
as you're taking out these highs 1600
positive Delta 1300 positive Delta
um you know I'm always watching the
Deltas
when you're sort of going back up into
these new highs you know quite strongly
you know 1100 right and you're seeing
you know the negative Deltas 400 300 and
it's not really moving off from the
highs right I always watch the the
strength of the pullbacks off of a high
especially if I see some strong selling
like this this is strong selling here
you know we're closing near our Min
Delta on
one two three bars
and
there's absolutely no follow-through
right it just goes inside of you on this
third bar on this fourth bar here
right and I know that once I get
potentially strong selling stronger
stronger I'm looking for this bar to you
know go from 37 down to or sorry from 77
down to 70. not just hang around inside
once you start seeing it inside that is
a sign that maybe this Market is
ignoring that that's that selling is
done and get ready for another leg back
up which it does
right and then you even get up in here
um again you start going sideways
there's some decent selling coming up
here to the highs 498 763 354 575 625
and the Market's just going sideways
right it's not selling off I mean
eventually it does start to come off a
bit I mean but you know under strong
selling but it's just not enough to
really push it back down towards the 50
area right it's just sort of hanging
around that 88s 90s and then again Works
its way back up again right you see some
more selling coming in here but even
though you got that selling it's not
really coming off okay and if you're
watching here right this is the simple
bar chart
and you know again you know sort of
follow up from the video that you know
we made the other day when you're making
new highs
Delta should be making new highs right
I'm always wary if the market is making
or sorry if Delta's making new highs
cumulative Delta but the Market's not
making highs so this is what you expect
to see and then you know when it gets a
bit later in the day
um you know what time is that three
o'clock
we start coming off a bit here again you
know but
it's you know we're above 3 900. you
know you're seeing the negative Deltas
500 700 1100 then just sort of goes
sideways because we're going into the
cash close already here right so
um you know what is that portend for
next week
hard to say honestly hard to say we're
up here 39 uh you know basically 39 14.
but we had that nice rally up and it was
a nice flow driven Market any pullbacks
you got were you know this was about as
deep as you got from three and a half
quarter down to six and a half more or
less that was only your only pullback
but then we based out and rallied back
up but on this move up you weren't
seeing you know necessarily strong
pullbacks on strong negative deltas
so anyway guys I hope you found this
video useful
you know be sure to uh subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already so thanks
everyone I'll see you guys on the next
video bye-bye